hello and welcome to playstation grenade
just cause 3 is crammed with easter eggs
cultural references memes and other
secrets
on your way to the platinum trophy
here's 33 moments we think you should
witness for yourself
the first easter egg is found in viso
plates in the trio region
this may take a little finding but
behind a small salmon pink building is a
section of the ruins with a small
handgun on top
this is the dk pistol picking it up will
instantly cause your head to expand
the gun itself doesn't harm anyone it
shoots but instead increases their head
size
kind of like a balloon
[Music]
the real wtf moment comes when you
decide to kill one of these balloon
people
because i love this so much i'm going to
keep dk mode on for the entire video
by the way the dk pistol is a callback
to the n64 and goldeneye where dk mode
could be unlocked making all characters
resemble
you guessed it donkey kong so it's kind
of like two easter eggs in one here
up at the intersection of grande pastura
and falco is a nerve jangling easter egg
referencing doctor who and the weeping
angels
in the middle of what looks like a
sacrificial altar are four angel statues
here's the issue they can and will move
closer to you
in the tv show a simple blink or split
second turn was enough for a weeping
angel to murder its prey
leave the area and come back if you want
the angels to reset their positions
at three spots around the island award
looked like missile silos
each has a set of buttons close by these
are in fact
wormholes to travel around the map the
code to drakon is two one four one two
four
to get to striate it's one four three
four
421
and 2 fonte it's 233-233 the
teleportation device resembles a
stargate in the film or tv show of the
same name
traveling through time also resembles
doctor who's intro sequence
another film reference can be found in
the most northwest part of the map
on a beach there is a bearded man living
alone with only a yellow lifeboat and
occasionally washed up packages
this mirrors the events of castaway
released back in 2000.
i tried my best to find wilson but he
wasn't there
another nintendo reference can be found
over by the bavarian nuke base
in falco at the top of the hill there
are two soap box carts one of which has
your friend mario in it ready to race
mario in a cart
[Applause]
this must be a nod to nintendo's leading
month by the way liberate the area first
or be prepared to avoid nukes and
endless gunfire
the crash bomb levels have been built to
resemble the delorean from back to the
future the cackle is randomized so
hopefully you'll get a silver version
and when the camera sits behind the
vehicle the similarities are prominent
in this game you are tasked with blowing
up an enemy stronghold
but there's one last nod to the back to
the future series when lightning erupts
from the explosions you cause
that just caused developers loved the tv
show lost in fact
in just cause 2 they made an island to
reflect the happenings in the show
as well as another handful of easter
eggs too in just cause 3 the lost
references
are back and come in the shape of the
smoke monster i stopped watching lost
before the identity of the smoke monster
was revealed
but i have seen its ability to kill
someone by simply touching them
back in game it's a bit of a waiting
game for the animations to trigger
first go over to the lake in maestali
and search out a small group of people
playing music and drinking
leave them for the moment and you will
find a fallen tree in the shape of an
arrow and the word run in wooden planks
if you follow these instructions and run
into the woods you'll hear the smoke
monster and if you get back to camp
quick enough
you can witness everyone dying
sadly i tried this for two hours and
this was the best i could do
sorry other people believe looking onto
the lake and waiting there for the sound
trigger is the best approach
but that didn't work for me
a little further north of the weeping
angels in grande pastora is a crater
but this crater has an easter egg stuck
in it find the middle and you will
discover thor's hammer
me on my ear your mini why why can't i
say that word
thor's hammer let's just deal with that
this of course is a nod to the god of
thunder thor
and the marvel movie version of him from
the 2011 film
if you can cast your mind that far back
it's where a host of people attempt to
lift the hammer including stan lee
they all failed of course
a little side reference when rico
attaches an enemy to an object
he says stick around in reference to
arnie
and the film predator
stick around on the island to the south
of the castaway easter egg you can
discover a cave in the shape of a face
this could be a reference to king kong
skull island
or school rock from peter pan my guess
would be king kong but the latest film
seems to have changed the cave designs
and now instead of a spine-tingling
scary sight it's this
i can't figure out what this reminds me
of welcome
whether through comic books film tv
deviant art or disneyland there's a few
variations to this design but you get
the idea
the comedy arrested development has an
easter egg in just cause 3.
the famous banana stun the family run is
here in medici
it was part of a long-running joke
whenever michael's father spoke about
the stand he would say
always money in a banana stand we don't
have the money pop
there's always money in the banana stand
after that banana stun was destroyed
he spelled it out a little more there's
250 000
lining the walls of the banana stand
there's
always money in the banana stand
back in the game you can destroy the
stand too and
he was right there is indeed money in
that banana stand
[Music]
over in masos there's a tipping area by
the side of the road
if you look hard enough a small dog is
there he'll begin to follow you
if you can get him across the road and
into his kennel
he'll reward you with doge mode by the
way i tried my hardest to kill the
little bugger
but he refused to be murdered and when
he's back home pause the game
and go to your options and you should
now have the ability to turn on doge
mode
shooting enemies now pops up typical
doge memes i didn't understand this meme
so i must be getting old
so i'll let behind the meme explain
let's just say there's a heavy emphasis
on the words much very so such and many
written in broken english as if the
animal is speaking to himself in his
head
back in regno a curved building can be
found with two ladies on the top floor
one is wearing a white and gold dress
the other a black and blue dress
this is a reference to the viral tweet
sent out in which people couldn't decide
if this dress was white and gold or
black and blue
what do you say well it turns out the
dress was black and blue
so that was resolved these ladies are no
longer required
up in the mountains of montana is a
final fantasy reference
embedded in the rock's face is clouds
buster sword from final fantasy vii
a pretty cool nod to the greatest ps1
game of all time
you can't make a video game these days
without referencing dark souls
it's an unwritten rule just cause 3 is
no exception on a hidden beach in north
calder is a sniper rifle surrounded by a
pile
of wood get the right angle and you can
ignite this bonfire just like those in
dark souls
back in regno and hidden on the side of
a building is a bit of graffiti which
doesn't tie in with the rest of the game
this in fact is the logo of youtuber
nerd cubed who was a huge supporter of
the series
a nice touch there to the south of the
lost easter egg is a boring old landfill
nothing to see here right well if you
disrupt the waste you'll be greeted by
hundreds of copies of just cars and just
caused two
this is most likely a reference to the
landfill in mexico which saw
thousands of copies of the atari title
et discarded after very poor sales
a cool little easter egg referencing the
simpsons can be found in just cause 3
but
only when you board the train once you
hop on board open the world map and
three new locations have been added
brockway north haverbrook and ogdenville
these are places the famous monorail put
on the map
so i'm told i've sold monorails to
brockway ogdenville and north haverbrook
and by gum it put them on the map
i traveled to each one of these new
locations but nothing could be found
there
but many people have reported that a
desirable heavy weapon and seaplane are
available here
just cause isn't all about comedy
references and video game trivia it also
gives its developers an outlet to honor
the lives of loved ones
four memorials can be found around the
game world honoring friends and family
i'll put each of the locations in the
description so if you want to go pay
your digital respects
the option's there just cause 3 likes to
reference the previous games in the
series
for example on a beach in costa suit is
the snowman from just cause two
we meet again mr snowman
[Music]
hello mr snowman remember the mile high
club
well that balloon burst and the business
sank quite literally
go over to the north of maestrale and
find the ruins both on top and below the
water
i can almost hear that annoying tune
that the mile high club played
incessantly in fact
it didn't just cause three either steal
a propaganda van
or alternately go up to the ruins at
aspera and turn on the boombox
just be careful it's airstrike city here
a rave well on the top of the cliff in
laco is a party
it's only accessible during the night so
fast travel repeatedly if need to be
here you'll find a familiar looking dj
it's bolo santosi from just cause 2
she led the reapers and now her war is
over she's moonlighting as a rave dj
my name is bolo santosi
i am the leader of the revolutionary
army known as the reapers
that's not the only easter egg at this
rave if he spawns in you should be able
to find a dancer
wearing a green morph suit this is a nod
to the tv show it's always sunny in
philadelphia and the alter ego mascot
created by charlie kelly
here just see for yourself green man is
saving your life right now bro
just go with the flow there's a few puns
i quite liked in just cause 3 such as
the just claws restaurant in libercio
there's also a reference to the
developing studio making the game on
many number plates
avalanche there's so many more weird
wonderful and random encounters
happening all around the open world
in the valdemar lake a couple of huge
rubber ducks can be dragged into the
water
making them rideable similarly to a jet
ski i suppose
in many locations there are branded cows
with blue horns which means you can
mount those
if that's what you like to do with your
spare time in regno there's a pogo stick
randomly left on a balcony for you to
try out
and finally in the woods at sante
federico there's a group of mime
artists training to be the best like no
one ever was
it's a very strange place to live in
this medici place so that's it that's 33
little easter eggs and references for
you to enjoy whilst playing just cause
3.
this video has been so much fun to make
i'm hoping to bring back the monthly
easter egg feature i used to have
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
you